aujourd'hui c'est pas faire de longs
discours pour vous présenter parce que
d'abord il aimerait pas ça sachez
seulement que ce rambo de la zone qu'on
a comparé à bruyant à brassens à brasles
a déjà vendu plus de trois millions
d'albums
alors il fait pas tellement de
télévision il n'aime pas tellement ça et
c'est vraiment un scoop qu'il ait
accepté de faire scoop à la une alors
pas de longues phrases seulement son
blaze voici renault
m
bonjour
ensuite merci qu'on l'aimé alors bonjour
bonjour alors tu sors un disque dans sa
nouvelle maison de disque que tu l'as
fait ou se disent que la fois en
amérique comme morgane de toi ou tu la
fois en france j'ai commencé aux états
unis je définis ici et tu l'as fait avec
qui je les fais avec des musiciens
américains sauf l'accordéoniste jean
louis roques et pour les musiques tu as
travaillé avec bucolo jean-pierre bucolo
franck langolff le compositeur de la
chanson pour l'ethiopie ouais
et puis et puis moi moi même et avec
jean philippe goude comme producteur
arrangeur réalisateur tout ça alors il
ya une chanson que que tout le monde
entend à la radio un petit peu c'est
ainsi que tu vas chanter pour la
première fois à la télé c'est miss maguy
et une autre chanson qui est très très
bien aussi c'est le retour de la paix
pet
ah ouais ça j'aime bien moi je trouve
alors là tu as fait une grande chanson
c'est une espèce de encore un espèce
d'hommage à boby lapointe
ouais au niveau de l'écriture en tout
cas espèce d'humour absurde c'est un
personnage que cav est déjà bien fait
marrer dans les autos tamponneuses dans
mon dernier disque wave j'avais pas
envie de faire disparaître comme ça je
voudrais que tu profites du fait d'être
à la télé pour faire le point parce
qu'il ya tout et font qui te regarde et
que tu leur parles un peu de deux trois
affaires récentes dont dans la presse
s'est fait écho mais dont je pense tu
t'es jamais expliqué à la télévision
alors la première c'est cette histoire
de moscou d'y aller à moscou pour
chanter tu t'es retrouvé dans une salle
et a chanté le déserteur et tout le
monde sait tirer alors là quand nous un
peu pourquoi comment bah voila j'ai
lancé le déserteur et tout le monde sait
tirer ça leur a pas plu mais après
l'euro ma chanson leur a pas plu dans
parlons plus ouais ils ont noms et tout
le monde s'est tu irais mais en fait
quand il avait rien compris aux paroles
et c'était pas des gens qui se sont
tirés parce qu'on leur demandait de se
tirer en quelque sorte
voilà et après qu'est ce qui s'est passé
après j'étais en colère j'étais très en
colère et j'ai craqué je me suis énervé
j'ai des conneries j'ai dit des trucs
bien g
les trucs tout ça sous l'oeil noir d'une
caméra qui était tenue par un pote à moi
qui m'a dit par la suite tu façon
t'inquiète pas si tu veux pas qu'on le
montrent ces images on les montrera pas
en rentrant à paris sur retrouver sur
terre un peu j'ai réfléchi et où je me
suis dit finalement c'est la colère que
j'ai piqué même si je renie pas ce que
j'ai dit ça regarde personne c'est privé
ça j'ai pas envie que 10 millions de
spectateurs voient me vois sortir mes
tripes et flip et angoissé je suis allé
voir mon pote et je lui dis devant de la
scène là dans les loges poubelle est
touché même nom c'est un scoop je fais
passer le droit à l'information tu
imagines mon émission sans cette scène
et tout j'ai plus rien à dire et tout
voilà que tu acceptes l'exhortent belge
avait pas choir il mais c'est pas une
émission sur moi c'était une mission
d'information donc ça fait partie même
juridiquement s'était pas je pouvais pas
pas interdire la diffusion de ce truc
perdu un pote quoi alors l'autre
chaussée l'ethiopie tu as fait ce disque
qu'on a tous adorent est avec l'anglais
fla en golf lors golfe
voilà c'était très bien puis après il ya
eu le concert de la courneuve alors là
c'est pareil et moins bien qu était
moins bien vrai
bah oui c'est bah oui si c'était moins
bien parce que c'était pas très bien
organisé par des gens dont c'est pas
forcément le métier d'organiser des
concerts ça s'est fait trop vite ou trop
ou trop tôt ou trop tard ça il n'y a pas
eu assez de pub et puis puis les gens
avaient peut-être un peu marre aussi de
ses concerts pour des causes
oui toujours bonne et puis et puis j'ai
pas mais t'as pas peur sur sa sur place
c'était bien le dire pour ceux qui
étaient là c'était ça s'est vraiment
passé formidablement le seul problème
c'est qu'il avait pas beaucoup de monde
t'as pas peur de devenir un peu
l'indigné de service non tu te méfies
pas de faire un peu mais fille si je
veux dire je suis assez sollicités pour
faire ou des chansons ou des galas pour
des causes
ouais diverses contre le racisme la
partie de la misère les nouveaux pauvres
et chômeurs le cancer le sida et où je
veux c'est de faire une sélection où
vraiment
forcément arbitraire mais quand je
m'investis dans un truc j'aime autant ce
soir de kim viennent du coeur et des
tripes merci voilà
des gonzesses qui avons qui vont payer
pour voir ça premier rang et tout l'art
ti briquet c'est pas de la fausse
modestie patois fille si le sait en
général c'est toi qui pose des questions
à l'intérieur tout a du change et
pourtant ton look reste identique et
m'arrive aussi battu un costard
par un costard non une veste par exemple
j'ai toujours les cheveux jaunes je
trouverais cheveux longs bon sens à ton
avis renault c'est quoi qu'il a de plus
énervant le chanteur énervant
enfin c'est
c'est que ça marche encore pas mal et
dans pas mal de gens sales
même des fois moi ça m'énerve je me dis
comment ça se fait que tu chantes pas
d'un pied toutes les guitares
hallucinante
et puis je fais des conneries je dis des
conneries puis il ya des gens qui
m'aiment bien quand même
bon alors enfant famille déchets la
ligne immobilier et si tu n'étais
rebelles que dans tes chansons
finalement un peu je crois pas en droit
d'être plus dans la vie que dans la
chanson encore battu à me demander ce
que j'ai fait aujourd'hui pour comme
acte de rébellion par exemple mais je
tiens pas une comptabilité mai
mais eux
la rébellion dans mes chansons c'est du
spectacle d'un million dans ma vie c'est
celle là donc je souffre vraiment et
c'est celle-là kim qu'il fait bouger
avancé et
qui donne envie de continuer c'est pas
le succès que j'ai sur scène qui me
donne envie de continuer c'est ma
révolte
aujourd'hui thé rouge et rose thé vert
ou thé noir quand les rouges et stahl me
voir me disant faut aider les mecs qui
sont en taule à tel endroit
il faut aider les ouvriers de chez
renault 4400 balle par mois bah je les
aide sans a priori négatif quand c'est
les noirs qui demande et soutenir des
objecteurs et déserteurs parce qu'il ya
que qui les soutient je me sens proche
d'eux c'est tout ça c'est ma famille
quoi mais même
c'est passé très multicolores pour moi
c'est famille de gauche mais les rouge
et noir les roses les verts alors comme
c'est ma famille c'est des gens que
j'aime bien je peux m'en violet avec les
membres de ma famille qui est rose
particulièrement
est ce que finalement renault je ne
serai pas le dernier survivant de mai 68
tu compares et julie
gens comme ça je pense que j'ai mieux
survécu
j'ai mieux survécu g il s'en va être
resté plus fidèle à cette époque a ses
idées d'amour et de révolte
ils ont pas qu'a toujours un avis sur
tout la hat échoué si vous vous demandez
tout le temps des avis sur tout j'arrive
pour faire une limite pour chanter une
chanson devant ce que je pense de la
guerre du liban lorsque par exemple de
l'interdiction des foulards coranique
dans les lycées parce que justement j'ai
un avis car je le donne on va croire
encore c'est une parole bénite
alors c'est un avis de crète deux avis
ça navigue me trompe dois je vais te
dire la même chose que je pourrais dire
dit ce matin les potes en buvant mon
café au petit déj tout ça un peu
mais qu'elle souhaite racisme c'est
clarisse pas conscience morale de gauche
et tous les footballs eric berthet
d'occulter tout
je considère que
liberté de culte et de croyance est tout
à fait respectable mais apparemment on
essaye de s'intégrer dans la société et
dans une école laïque
marc est à ce point là sa différence
c'est c'est pas franchement essaye de
s'intégrer passé justement essayer de
s'installer créer des ghettos tous à peu
elle tend à interdire c'est jaime face à
je m'embrouille sait plus quoi dire
ce matin au bistrot jde vachement bien
dit j'ai dit que bon alors si les mecs
ils arrivent avec leurs fins les
gonzesses plus tôt avec leur alors
tchador les [ __ ] avec leur calotte
qui chapeau noir le mentonnais
elle sert à créer des ghettos alors on
parle d'assimilation
intégration et où je trouve pas que ce
soit le meilleur moyen mais en même
temps dans le côté il faut respecter les
croyances et les traditions mais à
partir du moment où tu rentres dans une
école là tu veux faire ça tu fais une
école religieuse 6 à 6 heures il faut
que tu te mettre devant la mecque est
accomplie et pendant un cours de math
pour nous de choisir une école islamique
mais ces conflits pareil sur ces va être
pris pour des arguments fachos réac et
ou poitiers bien informée ça te fait
quoi quand président tonton mitterrand à
la télé annonce que affirme que
justement tu es mal informés j'ai alors
je vous dis [ __ ] il est bas et
recreuser ils s'en sortent toujours
renault formidable générosité très très
mal informé mon contrat j'étais très
très bien d'informer pour ça que j'ai
monté ce truc enfin que j'ai monté
ils ont monté qui vont pousser devant
pour aller expliquer d'être austère mais
j'étais très très bien informé quoi
hélas été informé qu'un gouvernement
socialiste à l'air
pendant les célébrations du bicentenaire
de la révolution
lien symbolique
vidéo 89
wallah
viens pas fouet
cuincy l'esa et ce sommet des sept pays
les plus riches du monde
les maîtres de l'école
al shamal il convient pas par exemple
qu'on parle de la chaîne musicale
uniquement avant les élections ainsi
j'ai été invité à un déjeuner un jour à
l'elysée avec
collègues chanteurs berger jane birkin
ça comme c'était juste après les
évènements en nouvelle calédonie je te
dis on va parler ça je vais balancer un
peu et puis en fait
c'était pour parler de la chaîne
musicale à l'époque ou tonton savait pas
encore s'il allait enfin n'avait pas
encore annoncé qu'il allait se
représenter
ce jour là j'ai une vie n'est qu' il
allait se représenter
il faisait venir des artistes pour
essayer de lui donner un peu
d'argumentation pour défendre telle
chaîne musicale qu'il suppose et ils
défendent en lui malgré quelques voix de
jeunes branchés musique
et puis
rappelons foot
et c'est une des choix zir de défendre
qu'une seule grande dose parce qu à
laquelle les enfants avant les hommes
les hommes avant les animaux les animaux
dans les arbres les arbres dans tout le
monde parce que à long terme plus
d'arbres c'est plus d'enfants
mais heureusement que 20 des fois je dis
malheureusement le choix est large vaste
dans mon courrier le matin quand je n'ai
plus fait plouf plouf
aujourd'hui je vais défendre les arbres
parce qu'en rase et là aujourd'hui je
vais lutter contre le barrage de cercle
la loire 1
ou alors claude plouffe les kurdes les
kanaks qu'elle donne les ardeurs des
formes très bien tout seul les les
immigrés les exclus les chômeurs les
pauvres les malades les handicapés les
villes vraiment c'est hallucinant je
suis des fois je me dis mais c'est moi
aussi je peux le chanteur je suis je
suis psychologue je suis docteur je suis
avocat je suis banquier je suis je suis
prêtre tuchan vrai quoi dans le monde si
tu avais une baguette magique
par exemple soir c'est ce qu'on va faire
ouais on va parler métier on va parler
show business ont à faire de la
promotion des ventes
tu es prêt tu alors ça c'est bien connu
alors on va commencer avec ton nouvel
album qui s'appelle visage pâle
rencontré public le renault tour 89 et
qui a été enregistré au printemps de
bourges le seuil ça ouais elle est
d'abord enregistré au zénith
klose élite les chansons c'est la
première fois qu'on les jouer sur scène
alors ça tournait pas bien quoi j'ai
écouté j'ai découvert poubelle alors
ouais je me demandais pourquoi savait
pas été refait à bourg ouais alors
est-ce que ça ça va pas d'un seul coup
quand même arrêter les ventes de [ __ ]
de camion façon les ventes de plus d'un
camion il ya notre récent arrêté
prenez à combien 450 mille six cent
cinquante mille six cent cinquante
ça y est quand même un double platine
depuis plusieurs mois non parce que les
deux d'avant la mistral gagnant et
morgane millions 2,1 millions de f et
puis d'un seul coup tu nous faisais 450
en compte une dizaine à les 150000 cio
qui dit qu'à 150 massive bigboo ouais
ouais mais c'est bien certifié par le
snep et bayrou mais franchement tu crois
que c'est dû à clore trois cas d'asthme
en du phénomène rome et paris il ya deux
williams arya pts et ça y est le fait
qu'il va être est ce que tu penses tu
penses tu pense que les gens sont
énervés par le chanteur énervant
ouais tu corresponds à une sensibilité
d'une époque tatou qui marche tout
baigne et tout
du correspond au créneau jean thème ce
que tu fais c'est de l'or est-ce que
c'est pas la qualité des choses il ya
peut-être ça aussi mais ça qui peut en
juger moi les gens que j'aime et qui
m'aime vraiment ils disent que c'est mon
meilleur album et moi j'en suis pas
convaincu je me dis aussi que je trouve
que c'est un et j'ai passé les autres et
des sources étaient bien et je laime -
celui-là c'est vrai donc j'ai peut-être
tué moins envie de le défendre
et puis il ya aussi le fait que pour au
moins 25 % que j'ai fait pas mal mais
quasiment pas des thonidés de pas faire
de promo c'était simplement parce que tu
t'es dit voilà c'est génial j'ai signé
un contrat avec virgin jeu par un
milliard huit sur trois albums je vis
sur mon bateau est dans la maison à
outremont québec côté de montréal ou
avignon ou arles avignon
et puis je renvoie les disques par la
poste non pas du tout c'est ça non mais
c'est vrai que c'est génial site web non
franchement j'ai pas pensé à ce n'était
pas ça ce n'était pas l'idée de te
couper du monde les gens les marlos
métier j'en ai marre des médias j'en ai
marre de la télé le paysage audiovisuel
tel qu'il est devenu neymar des
journalistes j'en ai marre de répondre
toujours une question
j'en ai marre de vendre mes chansons
même si c'était un produit alors de
départ c'est malgré tout ça reste une
oeuvre à quelque chose neuve
une oeuvre des repas au centre magique
les six mais c'est de la création
et puis d'excès sur un disque avec un
produit dès que tu dois toi même à les
vendre en radio achètent mon dernier
album le voilà il est beau je suis
meilleur je prends je vais faire peser
nietzsche du temps au temps et tout ça
je voulais plus jouer ce jeu là ça mais
ça me gonflait j'ai craché un les
marques et l heure après tu as dis quand
même bon mais je me suis planté
c'était un peu comme si j'avais dit je
vais me suicider je voulais pas mourir
quoi me voilà j'ai dit je veux plus les
gens connaissent les chansons j'avais
oublié la dimension d'abord
d'information des médias pour dire aux
gens mon disque est sorti mes chansons
je chante dans votre ville ce soir
et puis j'avais surtout oublier qu' il
ya des gens qui même si ses envies de le
livre est sorti d'abord quelque envie de
me voir chez sabatier été obligé d'y
aller
ouais mais j'ai du coup je fais ce
métier je suis pas les chirurgies rien
fait sur la vie dure
là où ça a été le fruit faut pas me le
dire c'est quand j'ai eu l'histoire du
zénith parce qu'encore le dise police
vent il se vend pas mais il a seul coup
quand on nage dans ta vie je pense que
c'est bertrand de labbey quantité a dit
mon pote cet amuse de chanter devant une
salle vide
là tu as dit non ça m'amuse pas du tout
ça ne l'est pas d'autant que j'avais
prévu de faire un bond au zénith avec un
beau spectacle avec un des spectacles ça
coûte cher
quand on m'a dit le spectacle coûte un
milliard il faut un milliard de recettes
pour l'amortir elle payé tout le monde
avant même que je gagnais un sentiment
que le producteur gagne 1 centime a fait
un rapide calcul il fallait cent mille
spectateurs alors sans faire télé sans
en parler aux gens sans aller dans les
journaux les radios passées et celles en
clair ça possible aussi aussi grand soit
tu cela dit bon je vais pas tenir le
discours de sheila aujourd'hui elle mais
bon j'ai dit ça finalement ça c'est pas
si mal passé beaux-arts j'ai fait 100
milles au près 20 milles du duo le
180000 la fois d'avant ouais c'est pas
mal bon travail il ya les mecs qui font
trois semaines en ce moment avec mac
qu'on fait 70 milles d'attraper coup
comment là à la sortie
abel goumba mans je suis parti en
tournée ouais bah j'ai fait deux trois
interviews dans deux trois journaux que
j'aimais bien fait j'ai décidé de faire
la promo de promo charge aux motions
archi sélective de faire les émissions
de jeux en que j'aime bien voir de faire
les interviews dans les journaux que
j'aime bien lire tout comme ça c'est pas
ta première défaite professionnels
normes et très bien bah ouais
apparemment
[Musique]
bon renom veut qu'on est à la télé j'ai
de poser les questions à la con mais
vraiment des questions très con par
exemple tu préfères ton père ou ta mère
ça commence bien
jeu j'aime les deux les deux m'ont
préserver du froid de la fin de
l'ignorance tu préfères hitler ou
staline staline
ah bon si j'ai joué mais entre la peste
et le choléra temps éclair il paraît
qu'il aimait beaucoup les animaux
tu dois partir à deux pendant trois ans
sur un vaisseau spatial choisiraient de
partir avec guy bedos anne sinclair ou
patrick bruel
combien d'années pour trois ans j'ai
peur se soignent sinclair pour raisons
alimentaires non élémentaire t'aurais pu
prendre guy bedos pour faire du lest si
tu avais pas le choix je préférerais
faire l'amour avec une fille très très
laide ou avec un mec très très beau si
j'avais vraiment pas moins qu'une lettre
allait mettre un filtre à l'aide tu
préfèrerais très incarnée en michel
drucker jean-pierre foucault ou patrick
sabatier michel drucker sans hésitation
a qui trouvent tue le plus de
circonstances atténuantes infusion qui
se tape des petites ou un jeune qui tape
sur la petite vieille qui se tape des
petites de quel âge 12 ans un jeune qui
tape sur les du ranch étoiles soir qui
est au fait le plus peur dans nos armes
ça le pen ou tapis l'open mais c'est
toujours pas et entre la peste et le
choléra
la peur de le pen doit pas besoin
ton avis renault y at il une vie avant
la mort probablement mais ce qu'il ya
une vie avant sacrée soirée jeux pas sûr
[Applaudissements]
la relève en toi
alors ça marche très très bien
tu te fais content ouais on disque
platine ouais quasiment ça c'est comme
arrêter dès le mec arrive on lui dit
qu'ils vont beaucoup de disques et le
single est classé au top 50 aussi ouais
t'as pas l'air content merci je suis
content de toi quand tu donnes un peu de
mal finalement quand tu fais un peu le
tour des médias
oui je vois que ça marche c'est pas
compliqué ça avait bien marché aussi
sans faire le tour des médias
quant à tout faire ma question promo et
passez moi ouais ils ont pas fan de toi
je suis a fait 3 td tu as fais plein de
télé intuit a vraiment donné du mal un
taff et martin ouais t'as fait bravo
ouais t'as fait drucker je fais le cabba
tafer elkabbach a tout fait et toi
qu'elle lui meilleur souvenir de cette
promo à part ce soir bien sûr de cette
tournée de promo c'est martin j'ai fait
aussi le journal de faire trois avec
paul amar
juste de 8h - et - 2 à 8 heures après il
ya la classe malawi parce qu'il s'était
c'était short comme c'est bien et
qu'elle était le pire souvenir je
m'attends à tout lé pire souvenir c'est
la presse écrite quoi ah ouais c'est
grave je passe des heures à raconter ta
vie à ces gens là je t'écoute il pose
des questions et tout mais après tu le
dis ça et puis tu t'y mais c'est pas
vrai c'est mon sosie qui a fait pas la
même chose du tout pas vraiment toi qui
avais dis ce que j'ai à dire c'est dans
mes chansons ont rien fait c'est pas
vrai les gens ils veulent te voir la td
de t'ecouter parlaient ils en ont pas
marre d'entendre également on est
content que tu sois là ah bon alors par
les hélices parler de politique à la con
et où sa prise de position
10 - marchand de cailloux marchand de
sable alors c'est et du comment de cette
idée le marchand de cailloux donc le
marchand de sable c'est pour endormir
les petits enfants et de marchand de
cailloux c'est pourrait réveiller paix
voilà tu te dis bien si je savais que la
dixième fois que tu dis mais toi dit
vachement bien c'est sur l'intifada
cette chanson non pas seulement c'est
surtout les endroits du monde où les
mômes qui jettent des cailloux aux
soldats connu qui leur tirent dessus à
balles hautes et d'irlande du nord sont
peut être à johannesburg
ça peut être à vaulx en velin il ya
cette chanson une chanson sur ton donc
et pas très très sympa quand même pas
très très méchante non plus avant de
trouver quand tu dis tout fois la gloire
qui s'en va et où c'est pas terrible je
suis regardé les chiffres et sondages en
fait est le plus connu des déçus du
socialisme toi finalement c'est
peut-être pas le plus déçu mais je suis
plus connu et le plus connu des déçus et
une chanson sur la corrida aussi oui ce
n est pas du tout la corrida un tu
parles des pétasses qui pose ses
commentaires sur les arènes nîmoises
c'était à revers la corrida que j'aime
pas que c'est vrai j'aime pas trop
j'aime pas du tout mais la chanson
traite plus d'une public féminin de la
corrida des parisiennes à la snob et
parisianisme snobisme tout ce qui tourne
autour
j'avais pas envie de faire une chanson
l'éternel débat pour ou contre la
corrida d'un côté les aficionados avec
leur culture leurs traditions leurs
arguments historiques presque religieuse
pour expliquer la beauté de la corrida
l'autre côté les zoophiles
j'ai pas me citer leurs noms mais c'est
vrai lui rendit dans l'autre tu voulais
parler d'un des aspects de la corrida je
trouve grotesque candidat c'est un
spectacle qui ne plaît pas parce que
c'est un spectacle de violences avec la
mort d'un animal mais je trouve pas plus
ignoble que les infos de 20 heures la
différence c'est que quand on bombarde
bagdad
il tape à 3000 colas qu'applaudi squale
il ya une chanson sur le paris-dakar
aussi relaté dû l'écrire avant que ce
soit paris le cap parce que tu dis 500
connard sur la ligne de départ du paris
dakar et mal en pire que tu ouvres au
cap salutaire mais ça non quand même pas
vrai je croyais qu'il allait bien finir
par crever de leur belle mort les gens
n'avaient plus rien à [ __ ] de leur
connerie et que ça commençait à fatiguer
tout le monde et puis là il rallonge le
parcours ils prennent tous continuent à
traverser des délégitimiser les régimes
ignobles comme la libye ou continuer à
faire de l'afrique une cour de
récréation mais la libye sans scrupules
l'afrique du sud et à l'on dit rien à
une de chansons on a cru reconnaître
nova non c'était pas lui du tout un bon
j'avais une rime jeu c'est l'histoire
d'un mec qu'il essaie de placer ses
chansons à droite à gauche personne en
veut à la fin il se retrouve bon c'est
moi le mec je retrouvais qu'une chanson
craignos je cherche une rime je dis bon
un crâne chanson craignos roland garros
je prends un blaireau qui sort de roland
garros
judith est beau et et qu'on va faire de
toi un petit chanteur à la con pour
faire un succès des t1 de chansons
chanteur éphémère mecs qui font les
tubes de l'été quoi les chanteurs d'un
slot j'arrive au québec il ya quelques
mois l'a étonné que dia est bien à son
dernier disque a été tourné son bambin
belle y en a une seule touche
hardy donc est ce que tu lis mes actes à
yannick noah dans mon disque
bas-saint-laurent garros est un chanteur
le plein d'eau que numéro 1 tout l'été
ensuite on a demandé à de parler de
yannick noah est ce que je pense et lui
comme comme artiste et à dire on sait
pas ses chambres pour orangina pour la
commune compte la galerie white certaine
confusion dans ces chansons là ces
espèces de son espèce de lambada à un
coup envoyé
non c'est vrai sa chanson un peu third
world music toi world music tu vois
africaine au sud africaine zoulou et
puis à côté il y avait pu pour la même
chanson qui servait pour une pub pour
les mars où les lions bounty les lions
les lions alors ça fait un peu confusion
tout ça valait la télé maintenant qu'on
a parlé de ton déjà suivi la sphère
bilalian mardi soir là tu en penses quoi
toi tu penses qu'il fallait le dire eh
ouais donc il a raison mais pas que lui
il faut virer tous les mecs qui font de
la propagande pour le fascisme et le
nazisme sous couvert de faire de
l'information on en a rien à [ __ ]
d'entendre des idées à gervais faut pas
laisser s'exprimer c'est vrai enfin
s'exprime déjà tous seuls dans leur vie
quotidienne dans la rue donc pas de
liberté pour les ennemis de la liberté
mais ils sont libres mais qu'on les
invite pas à la télé on est dans
l'ensemble en le jouant les vierges
effarouchées à problèmes tant choqué et
tout peut passer mais qui pâtissait pas
de la théorie c'est pas d'idéologie
cesser de laisser le vomissent qui
balancent quoi quand j'entends parler
ces gens là j'ai envie de leur dire
articule quand tu pètes
et la chaîne musicale alors parce que la
dernière fois que tu en as entendu
parler c'est en 88 mitterrand avait
invité à l'elysée pour ans pour en
parler
et tu t'es dit quand il était allé où il
va se représenter le vieux parce que
quand il commence à voir des artistes
pour leur parler de la chaîne musicale
c'est que l'électorat jeune ça le tente
il a été réélu il ya des gens pas la
bonne musique ap
voilà vaincu ces déçus la belle se cache
pas que franchement paraît que c'est
important pour la création tout culture
pour la musique pour les jeunes
créateurs étupes mois les chaînes de
télé je trouve ça franchement beaucoup
trop quoi déjà je veux dire c'est pas
mon cheval de bataille
mais la chaîne bus des causes perdues
justement est ce que tu aurais envie de
défendre à cinq par exemple puisque tu
auras envie de la défendre cette chaîne
au wac il est vrai en tout cas si une
plainte petit mais je ne défends pas
tous des fois on les plus faibles il ya
des gens quand même où l'info tu as
vraiment foutu les boules
c'était pendant la guerre du golfe là tu
t'es tu t'es vraiment énervé tu veux
appeler ça une boucherie mais b us her
yeux et c'était vraiment énervé ça un
peu oui pourquoi
et pour plein de raisons déjà voir les
médias donc tu es fait partie tu vois
des mecs des journalistes français et
habillé en treillis camouflage kaki dans
le désert en train de
habillés en militaires en train de nous
donner comme information ce qu'ils
recevaient de l'état major américain
je trouve que c'est sûr ça pitoyable
quoi réaliser que toute démocratie qu'on
soit quand le pouvoir veut museler la
presse et les journalistes
son regard là vous donc ça ça m'a fait
germer depuis c'était une bière pour ce
que j'ai pas aimé c'est l'hypocrisie du
discours que la guerre du droit pour
rétablir la démocratie elle arrête
abiquo aller les ennemis
c'est clair j'ai que jalabert corbett a
dit un truc bien sûr les convertis au
passage qui est assez drôle tu dis avant
au couvercle coverity était sur son
boïko et la femme marché derrière
maintenant elle marche devant à cause
des mines
oui c'est vrai ça m'arrive en dessin et
c'est sûrement vrai en plus c'est bon
pour virer saddam hussein ils l'ont
ravir elle est toujours là il est plus
puissant que jamais maintenant c'est un
héros aux yeux du monde arabe le
problème palestinien on devait entrer
dans cette guerre pour être à la table
des négociations on n'a même pas un
strapontin
tu as marqué sur la sur la pochette de
son disque enregistré pendant leur sale
guerre c'est vraiment quelque chose de
laid courage à ces courageux oui parce
que tu t'es fait quand même traité de
sade amis de vichyssois de collabos
collabos d'antisémite
ouais on a dit que tu voulais rayer
israël de la carte c'est pas on alice
guy bedos quel est ce mal posée quand je
disais libérer la palestine j'entendais
par palestine autre chose que les
territoires occupés et que donc il a
écrit dans un journal en pleine guerre
du golfe que je voulais gomme et israël
vous voyez déjà avec une bombe en
apporte moi puisque aurait pu être
concevable en plus de la part des juifs
mais qui peuvent rayer israël de la
carte
je lui ai répondu que c'était une tête
de con et que ses propos étaient quand
même dans seulement nul mais dangereux
comme une honte pour moi pour les miens
et tous vous êtes bien gueuler un iphone
et un an après tu persistes et us in sur
la condamnation de la guerre du yom ha
ouais encore plus encore plus
bah oui a engendré un génocide enfin
massacre de kurdes de plus
saddam a liquidé son opposition ces
kurdes et tout tranquille marc les
curetons est revenu aussi parce que tu
t'es aperçus qu'ils avaient massacré les
arméniens c'est compliqué tout ce que
vous avez collaboré facteurs participer
quelques-uns d'entre eux ils sont pas
tout blanc blanc blanc personne n'est
blanc banon il ya plein de gens comme ça
qui t'avait kit avait soutenu et puis
qui finalement sont un peu détaché de
toi je vais donner des noms comme ça au
hasard
anne sinclair par exemple m'a soutenu de
l'anc et les élections à l'époque où tu
faisais les beaux jours du magazine
globe et tous anne sinclair était quand
même faisait partie des gens qui tu es
mais bien d'être un peu la bonne
conscience de la gauche
et même plus maintenant je crois que
tous ces gens là t'aime beaucoup moins
qu'avant mais enfin tu dois t'en douter
non ouais bernard henri lévy par exemple
je sais pas je te cite des gens danser
comme le tir au pigeon d'argile
non mais c'est des gens se séparent à
ces gens que j'aime pas conseillé les
mâles et du pouvoir et lèche-bottes des
socialo les gens qui jugent qu'ils
condamnent qui des donneurs de leçons et
où il ya un type qui était un peu
remplacé comme une conscience de la
gauche c'est bruel ah bon tu as gaffes
et qu'il y aller un peu aux chalands à
la ma place alors qu'un succès maga ce
n'est pas lui la gamme charland que
concurrent quoi ouais des jaloux de lui
pas jaloux mais c'est toujours énervant
quand il ya un mec qui pulvérise des
scores 1 ce niveau là quoi je veux dire
c est quand même une compétition ce
métier on a toujours envie d'être le
premier meilleur ou dans le groupe de
tête et a dit qu'il n'avait rien à dire
je dis ça moi oui ballottés tout j'ai
jamais 10,1 en politiste jeudi qu'il
avait rien à dire et il était l'un des
liens et il fallait le lire l'article et
taylor hall a repris un jour on a parlé
de laurent fabius et tu as dit je
préfère che guevara c'est toujours vrai
nom mais j'avais lu un article d'une
gamine de 20 ans personnage que vous
préférez c'était laurent fabius un idéal
de société ouverte chez bva non mais je
peux en tout cas 20 ans je préfère être
gérée par an et encore aujourd'hui plus
que 28 en pense quoi
c'est un non c'est même pas un bon
gestionnaire d'une équipe de football de
bonne équipe de football là je vais dire
apparemment les résultats sont bons non
c'est un mec que j'aime pas trop quoi
que c'est assez un fender cgc
diffamatoires ça
non je veux dire on parle soit c'est ces
entreprises qui rachète et tout qui fait
soi disant refleurir en fait il y faire
fleurir en licenciant 90% les ouvriers
qui se retrouvent à la rue aux nouveaux
restaurants du coeur serge july tu dis
maintenant il défend la
social-démocratie et lucien les mails
dernière le premier arabe
alors c'est mort parce que le seul qui
trouve grâce à ses yeux ces gens et
cavaliers ouais je dis j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour joindre un délit alors
il aime bien jouer de la avoir beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui 6 1 2 6 6 d'abord
parce que c'est une plus grand écrivain
un des plus grands écrivains français
vivant c'est ce que mitterrand lui a dit
d'ailleurs lui et un jour et
et puis c'est un fou qu'il a peur de
rien c'est un homme libre c'est un
sauvage a intéressé 1 c1 puis série
diamant il est génial
et puis j'essaie de le faire taire
j'aimerais les mecs qu'on essaie de
faire taire il ya 20 ans d'interdits et
carly hebdo pour le bal tragique à
colombey
aujourd'hui on fout des procès en
diffamation et cpe parce que c'est plus
grosse dame en oui les grosses amendes
on n'a jamais vu ça dans l'histoire de
la presse 1 million 800 mille nouveaux
180 pic d'avant pour diffamation envers
les ripoux c'est bien tu te ramolli
passe autour d'albert pis tout ça c'est
bien tu travaillais pas trop le pen tu
as dit aujourd'hui si on veut être un
saint cathodique
il faut balancer sur le plein je suis un
petit peu énervé quoi parler ces espèces
de tous les artistes ou les
intellectuels tous les journalistes tous
ces mecs qui arrivent à la télé qui font
leur petit couplet anti l'open quoi
ras-le-bol cps-2 c'est comment dire
c'est une espèce de créneaux quoi toi de
positionnement marketing c'est venu un
positionnement marketing humaniste aux
droits de l'homme art mais ça tu aimes
pas en dix mois
coluche gainsbourg montant sa touche et
disparitions d'enfants
ouais tu les bienvenus j'aimais bien
l'artiste le globe d'opposition pas trop
près quand il fait ses émissions de télé
vive la crise vive la guerre qui vous
expliquer aux yeux dans les yeux
pourquoi elle va l'aider à ses besoins
et pas des pershing pourquoi il y aurait
la guerre si on faisait pas comme ci ou
comme ça pourquoi la crise était
inévitable qu'il fallait se serrer la
ceinture et tout et je mens 80 au
passage tous à se lever un peu gonflé
mais l'artiste le comédien et chanteur
c'était vraiment un grand état beaucoup
sur les autres mais on va savoir ce que
tu es alors à faire un test on va
prendre toutes les couleurs comme ça de
l'arc en ciel politique et on va essayer
de savoir
je savais moi même elle va pas on va
t'aider on va essayer de savoir à
laquelle tu devrais faire vraiment alors
rose on peut plus dire que tu sois rose
maintenant tu n'es plus donc le louvre a
mérité aux écoutes moi j'ai vu des pages
dans libé on avait payé toi avec ton
temps les spas béton et ouais mais ça
c'est un acte de civisme de citoyens qui
avaient les moyens de se payer une page
dans matrix paris de signer un des
lecteurs
ouais ouais enfin tu disais tonton
laisse pas béton goudron est amusant il
y avait derrière lui les autres les
massacre d'ouvéa là les assassins
bernard pons et compagnie qui arrivent
et les bavures policières malik
oussékine où le groupe hass quang minh
tu voulais qu'ils reviennent ces bandits
ah non tout mais pas ça on va voir si tu
es rouge tu as dis je préfèrerais être
cubain que haïtien ouais explique tout
ça mais je préfère les mecs se marre pas
tellement là histoire pas tellement mais
ils bouffent way et ils ont l'éducation
le pain peut-être pas trop la liberté
bon mais haïti ils sont massacrés
l'opprimé et ils crèvent de faim en plus
je dis je préférais l'ancien ordre du
monde plutôt que le nouvel ordre du
monde celui de bush préférait quand tu
avais une union soviétique très très
forte que le travail qu'on y avait de
quoi tuer un seul centre mots ignoble je
préférerais qu'il y avait il y avait une
force pour compenser le capitalisme donc
je vais me relaxer et même avec ses
erreurs et ses excès jusque là serait
plutôt rouge d'après le test jeudi
je chanterai à la fête de l'huma et pas
seulement parce que c'est une grande
fête populaire
bah ouais quand tu prends johnny qui a
fait de lima il y va parce qu'il ya du
monde là
populaire moi j'ai chanté à la fête de
l'huma c'est elle c'est hier une façon
aussi les certains engagements est-ce
que tu serais vert parce que là aussi tu
aimes bien les verts mais en même temps
tu dis il y en a pas mal qui sont vert
de gris
ouais explique toi bats les vrais verts
sont ceux qui acceptent pas l'ordre
économique mondial tel qu'il est qui
savent que le l'environnement la
pollution tout ça ça sera c'est un
combat perdu d'avancé
si on change pas le système qui fait
qu'il ya un tiers de la planète qui vit
sur les deux autres tiers qu'il ya 85 25
% des humains et des pays qui concerne
85 % des ressources donc la tvr dans
cette limite le web est-ce que tu serais
noir et anarchistes c'est cela qui
définirait une certaine tendresse pour
les anars vais donc tu serais rouge noir
plus tôt
c'est pas j'essaye de ce même pouvoir
vert rouge noir vert voilà mais tout
n'est pas rose et pas besoin en dix ans
bgr rose je suis pas rose et j'ai
toujours le coeur un peu rose même temps
respect social au sens gouré il fait
mais ça fait dix ans qu'ils sont là il
faut qu'ils se prennent un peu de
vacances le résistions qui s'intéresse
beaucoup aux gens pacsés des chansons
sur les problèmes légende le monde
comment il va pas est-ce que tu connais
le prix d'un ticket de métro de
questions qui ont déjà été posées mais à
présent dans l'hypocrisie parce que ça
va faire dix ans je prends pas le métro
et j'en ai pas honte du tout parce que
j'aime pas ça tu te souviens il ya trop
de monde et parce que je suis trop c'est
trop et je suis parano et et puis parce
que j'ai une bagnole et puis que je
perdais beaucoup moins une qui roule
bien et que est ce que laisse à lui a
coûté trois francs 50 je sais pas je
sais pas non plus changé ton look way
ainsi qu'en marge et mes cheveux les
cheveux whip il est compliqué côtelettes
l'aller hoflack est toujours temps
poulbot tatoué sur l'épaule
bah oui mais c'est pour toujours oui tu
regrettes pas des jours quand tu prends
ta douche de voir ça sur l'épaule non
non tout content j'ai pas que ça en plus
t'as quoi c'est un aigle j'ai une
grossesse qui demande de l'italie avec
dominique et puis ça lui fait de la
lecture
alors tu es tu as dit on peut être que
tu as changé ton look parce que tu
voyais des renault par tous c'est à dire
que tu dis par exemple que tu avais un
foulard rouge autour du cou
tu ne m'était vous pouviez quinze jours
après au premier rang il avait quinze
mecs avec des foulards ou je trouvais
moi c'est ça ouais dans cette info que
pour ça non mais savait que c'était un
peu agaçant ce phénomène
d'identification auprès des banques pour
trouver qui tu es mais ils s'habillaient
comme toi bonnet vraiment moi-même
j'étais une caricature où je sais pas si
c'était ou au moins tu vois les mecs
vous voyez dans la rue régale de
l'habiller comme renault autour mais
c'est sa ex nom et est devenu du mal
pour être star maintenant que tu espères
tu as l'air de vivre assez mal de
célébrité de noms mais je sais pas tu
dis quand je vais au megastore par
exemple je garde mon casque de moto le
plus longtemps possible sur la place tu
l'as dis cela mais j'aime pas et dans
les endroits publics quelqu'un d'autre
ou tu te dis je serai plus à l'aise
finalement si je chantais à l'abri des
oreilles un peu comme ça je serais plus
plus tranquille quoi à l'abri des bravo
voilà bruit de l'argent et des oreilles
le journaliste qui posait des questions
l ai dit ce mot gêne pas de chanter puis
que vous dise deviennent des vos
chansons deviennent des vins produits
vous même vous soyez un produit de
consommation
une consommation de 7 domaines fasse
partie de l'industrie du capitalisme
tout ça je suis dit peut-être quelque
part au fond mon subconscient
j'aurais préféré tu vois vivent dans les
pays totalitaires et chanter des
chansons dans à l'ombre d'une cave à
l'abri des oreilles de la milice de la
milice
alors pour être un prologue et quoi
comme le fait si le pen était là tu
vivrais dans un petit hôtel est planté
pour chanter dix mois alors un moment on
parle de pétition contre le
réchauffement de la planète à moi aussi
je suis athée cancer
dans une pub des pétitions attendus ou
et des pétitions de la tour de bras
c'est assez c'est vrai qu'elles arrivent
par fax chez toi maman j'ai tous les
matins avec quelques-unes comme ça et tu
laisses ils n'ont jamais quoi trois par
semaine comme c'est à la fois par
semaine la dernière c'est là qu'elle par
exemple c'était pour la suppression du
double jeu celle là jean merci pour pour
contre la fermeture d'un centre culturel
en turquie c'est tous les militaires
avaient fermé pour cinq bien sûr elle et
les jeunes là dedans on la musique est
toute puissante à pétition pour le
retour à la monarchie bottines les choux
qui fait alors question écologique en
même temps toujours un militant tu
plantes des arbres etc
bertrand veut un peu à cousteau tout le
monde aime bien costaud toi comme tu as
une grande gueule et puis tu aimes bien
l'ouvrir tadic houston il a réussi à me
fâcher mais non non c'est pas ça mais
c'est que cousteau tu as dit tu as
raison il aurait mieux fait de venir à
la centrale nucléaire de nogent sur
seine
parce que c'était plus important pour
nos enfants que de se battre contre les
crados non c'est s'énerver une fois dans
sa vie pousse au vrai vécu longtemps
c'est quand isséens sur un digne et
entre les cra d'autres appels et
palabres image vient de mourir de rire
les enfants à l'école elle qui faisait
mourir de rire les parents de c'était
vraiment drôle ton écologie personnel
formé au parce que je vois que tu fume
des cigarettes quand même ses mauvais
choix pourrais tu me fais penser tu vas
pas nous faire avec les cigarettes comme
foucault et martin avec les régimes
soient pas t'arrêter recommence et
arrêté recommencer dans la jarre est ce
fini car c'est en terminale
donc c'est le 11 mai 92 10 ans le donc
si vous le voyez fumer après le 11 mai
92 prévu pour engueuler
honte à toi tu étais déjà confessé quand
même quand tu étais petit ah non jamais
jamais chez toi ont pratiqué pas ça chez
moi on n'était ni pratique en y croyant
ah bon j'étais jamais qu'on fait c'est
de ta vie tu veux essayer
c'est obligé ah oui c'est obligé bon
alors si tu me suis alors viens avec moi
et
[Musique]
es-tu favorable au divorce légalement je
trouve ça bien que ce soit le divorce
est autorisée bien sûr mais je trouve ça
pas bien que les gens divorce et à
l'avortement
c'est dommage c'est dommage qui est des
circonstances où les femmes sont
obligées d'avorter mais il faut bien
évidemment le continuer à faire en sorte
que les les lois qu'ils autorisent soit
respectée partout qu'il qui rendent
l'avortement libre gratuit si le des
criminalise que ces lois soient
maintenus ou créés à l'euthanasie
j'ai préféré que chacun puisse faire son
testament et dire non mais c'est
vachement compliqué ça à partir de quand
est-ce qu'on peut décider qu'un mec
souffre trop et que s'il est inconscient
chez pas la question des routes et
priori je m'en fous à la peine de mort
bah non
même pour les assassins d'enfants c'est
à ces questions vicieuse et obsède par
excellence même pour les assassins
d'enfants
c'est la question piège mais quoi qu'il
arrive une société civilisée peut pas
trancher la tête un individu
quoi qu'il ait fait et tu favorable au
droit de vote pour les immigrés ouais
plus tôt
est ce que tu crois en dieu non mais je
fais gaffe quand même et je me conduis
comme disait brassens
je me conduis qu'il ya plus mal que si
j'avais la foi si tu avais un dernier
message
débrouillarde sur un dernier message à
donner à ta petite fille serait quoi ça
y est tu peux toucher avec à la pêche
j'accueille reno et mélanie bettencourt
mairie
formés là ni la dernière fois que vous
êtes venu j'espérais que ce fut la
dernière il n'en est rien votre mère
ingrid betancourt 42 ans ex candidate
des verts à la présidentielle en
colombie est toujours détenu depuis le
23 février 2002 par la guérilla marxiste
des farc les forces armées
révolutionnaires de colombie
en fait la branche armée du parti
communiste colombien voilà alors
jusqu'au 23 février 2002 votre maman il
répète en cours avait mené contre la
pauvreté la corruption et le trafic de
drogue une lutte exemplaire qui ne peut
que susciter notre respect
alors mélanie j'avais donc trois ans et
demi et velvet en cours est otage des
farc
quand avez vous eu des nouvelles pour la
dernière fois ma les dernières nouvelles
que nous avons aidé elles datent
maintenant il ya plus de 2 ans voit une
preuve de vignes cassette vidéo pour
elle était forte
tellement forte mais à des pions n'a
rien on n'a pas de preuves de vie
on sait que tu envie quand on interview
raul reyes qui est le numéro deux des
farc qui dit toujours que qu'elle est en
bonne santé comme les autres otages mais
ce n'est pas une preuve de vie mais oui
bien sûr on la sent suivante alors
renault c'est au troisième anniversaire
de sa détention que vous avez pris
contact avec le comité de soutien à
ingrid betancourt vous restez plus tôt
je regrette ce que prédisent un peu mais
bon le mans où le jour où je les fais il
se trouve que dans le comité bettencourt
info et dans les comités de soutien j'ai
était non seulement le seul chanteur à
être présent à manifester ma solidarité
et j'étais aussi la seule personnalité
des personnes à part marek halter qui a
participé à quelques actions dans les
rues et dans les sur la parvis des
droits de l'homme avec les amis les
membres anonymes des comités de soutien
et la famille bettencourt
donc il est jamais trop tard et
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres artistes qui
ont rejoint ce combat et de mananara
d'autres encore et j'essaie mes petits
moyens de motiver les artistes
internationaux qui ont participé à
travers une chanson à sensibiliser les
populations en france et partout dans le
monde pour alors aujourd'hui voudriez
que la mobilisation pour une ride
bettencourt soit comparable à celle qui
a eu pour florence aubenas par exemple
c'est à dire une mobilisation générale
ces éléments lui c'était formidable
c'est eu lieu pour les airs otages
français en irak
je regrette que ce soit pas le cas pour
les bettencourt pendant la prochaine
manifestation pour ingrid betancourt
s'est lundi le 24 octobre à 19h au
théâtre du rond-point s'est situé au
rond point des champs elysées et vous
avez chanté la chanson que avec bucolo
vous avez écrite pour elle qu'on lui
colle oif et musique est absolument
magnifique
très
espèce dean faisant un peu pensé
musicalement à ce qu'a été sa cohérente
et il ya une vingtaine d'années une
chanson très mélodies très porteuse qui
m'aimait mot même putney mes petits mots
en valeur samson était en train d'être
adapté par johnny clegg pour l'europe et
l'afrique
les la version espagnole par un artiste
argentin excellent melingo qui est
formidable et aussitôt on va en faire
fabriquer une centaine d'exemplaires
pour l'envoyer très vite en colombie où
des radios libres
la diffuseront en espérant que les
otages entendront ce message de
solidarité de fraternité un des artistes
et des citoyens européens
le sera
3 ap
rageant
[Musique]
avec ses portes
dès janvier
ce site austalie milieu ou de riz
mao à toi qui
j'imagine
vers le haut
peut-être
moi et
fils de tshela
de l'umih
sofia
c
et le mal et surtout les attendons ils
seront libres de continuer sera les
images qui ont été réalisées par un
artiste motivé concerné aussi qui de son
côté dans ses concerts aussi prend à
partie le public pour les appeler à leur
soutien c'est romane serda qui régit ces
images ma petite femme que j'aime et que
j'en passe
c'est une si belle chance j'avais sur
une chanson pouvait faire bouger des
choses comme ça mais je ne sais pas à
quel point la difficulté de la famille
bettencourt des gens des comités de
soutien en facilité ou non d'avoir accès
aux médias les vingt deux micros tendus
c'était une chanson porté par un
chanteur connu arrive sur ce sujet pour
que des demandes d'interviews de caméras
de tous deux du monde entier trois jours
après la première diffusion de cette
chanson c'est votre meilleure amie
fogiel la semaine dernière j'ai une
demande d'interview d'une radio en
direct en direct de bogota et j'ai pu
adresser au peuple colombien aux otages
colombiens peut-être espérons et à une
grille bien sûr et à clara rojas son ami
un message de solidarité des citoyens du
monde à travers cette interview j'espère
qu'il y en aura d'autres
voilà j'espère que la version espagnole
touchera toute l'amérique du sud et la
version anglaise
le reste de la planète et la nation
française forcément la suisse la
belgique la francophonie quoi français
les québec
je pense que les chansons de johnny
clegg ont plus se fait pour la
libération de nelson mandela pour la fin
de l'apartheid que tout les résidents
résolution de l'onu
et voilà c'était un petit coup de
chapeau au passage les combattre
question chez nous qui était otage en
irak avec brel bruno a dit le pire pour
un otage
c'est de se sentir oubliés donc la grâce
à vous et grâce à tout ce qui est fait
on espère qu ingrid ne se sentira pas
complètement oublié mais met la pression
sur le gouvernement français en lui
demandant de se mobiliser
est ce que c'est une bonne stratégie est
ce que ça risque pas de braquer le
président uribe contre nous ou duel à la
cour suprême en colombie a accepté que
willy eu le président que l'on actuels
puissent se représenter aux prochaines
élections qui ont lieu en colombie en
mai 2006 il a changé la constitution
pour ça faut comprendre que il a
complètement un double langage quand il
a été élu il ya bientôt quatre ans une
première chose qu'il a faite c'est aller
chez ma grand mère et lui dire je ferai
tout pour que ingrid et les otages
reviennent mais depuis il n'a fait que
stopper toutes les initiatives tous les
moments où penser qu enfin on allait
aboutir à quelque chose que vous être un
dialogue allait s'ouvrir à chaque moment
il a tout fait pour empêcher que quelque
chose se produise donc
donc il faut comprendre que il faut
mettre de la pression sur le
gouvernement que l'on dit ici et
maintenant que les élections qui est
âpre qui approchent c'est un moment très
important pour nous c'est une fenêtre
qui s'ouvre
on a jusqu'à mai 2005 c'est uniquement
voilà c'est quand j'ai entendu parler
comme ça et ans et demi ou deux à la
télévision que j'étais bouleversée par
son courage et son ce sont vous êtes
très courageux aussi renault pour qu'un
courage civique faire fogiel et ardisson
à deux semaines d'intervalle ça oui
pour un joueur prenons les farc les
forces armées révolutionnaires
colombiennes la branche armée du parti
communiste colombiens y luttent contre
la pauvreté
ouiiiii lutte contre la corruption etc
des choses que vous défendrez volumes
additionnels de poser ses questions oui
idéologiquement je soutiens en leur
combat contre l'oppression entre la
misère contre
l'ignorance contre la malnutrition
d'entre le manque d'éducation le manque
de liberté dans leur pays comme je
soutiens toutes les libérations des
peuples et lutte armée
csc leurs méthodes pour lutter pour
l'heure leur idée utiliser le kidnapping
de masse 3000 4200 otage aujourd'hui en
colombie les derniers chiffres
trente mille morts par an les exactions
quand ils arrivent dans les villages
qu'ils ont obligés à enrôler les paysans
de force en leur promettant 3 dollars
par jour ce qui nourrit toute une
famille de paysans quand ils trafiquent
la drogue sont richissimes les
dirigeants des farc parce qu'ils sont
ici font partie des cartels de
distribution de la drogue dans le monde
entier je dénonce totalement ces
méthodes qui discrédite leurs combats
futiles beau à l'origine au départ
[Musique]
on va changer lisez
avec sinik hortefeux
janvier
je fais un petit interview chanson
française en eau est ce que comme
charles aznavour vous pensez que la
misère est moins pénible au soleil
je penche la misère et pénible partout
soleil ou à l'ombre
est ce que comme jacques brel vous
pensez que les bourgeois c'est comme les
cochons
j'appelle bourse soit celui qui pense
allemand disais je ne sais plus qui est
ce que comme georges brassens vous
pensez que 95 fois sur 100 la femme
s'emmerde en [ __ ] par la mienne est
ce que comme edith piaf vous pourriez
vous teindre en blonde si je vous le
demandait j'ai passé la moitié de ma
carrière teints en blond mon âge est ce
que comme léo ferré vous pensez qu'avec
le temps oui tout s'en va
non je pense que des îles et qui reste
des sentiments qui reste des convictions
qui reste est ce que comme gilbert
bécaud vous diriez que l'important c'est
la rose
elle est un peu fanée en france la rose
est ce que comme michel polnareff vous
pensez qu'on ira tous au paradis même -
non mais les ordures qui mérite vraiment
pas le paradis ici s'il ya un paradis
j'espère qu'ils aussi un enfer pour
certains une crapule dans ce monde
est ce que comme eddy mitchell vous vous
dites que s'il n'en reste qu'un vous
serez celui là j'espère j'espère que
j'emmerde les gens qui m'emmerde simon
pour une équipe tourisme avis qui font
que l'homme le plus heureux que je suis
qui est la santé le bonheur l'amour une
famille extraordinaire des amis un
public le plus meirieu plus public de
france
un métier qui me passionne et et voilà
ce le fait que ce bonheur puisse pas
être partagée par l'humanité entière
ça me pourrit mon bonheur ça me pourrit
ma vie ça me gâche la vie et tant qu'il
y aura un chien malheureux sur cette
planète je serai pas frêche pourrait
jamais être le plus heureux du monde
dont j'en veux à ceux qui essaient de
s'entraîner aujourd'hui que bonjour
bonjour les hirondelles
oui et c'est comme tout françois si vous
aviez un marteau vous tapez auriez le
jour la nuit tout à parier sur qui
d'ailleurs va écouter mon prochain album
verra il ya quelques ann a quelques-uns
qui déroutent campagne plein plein plein
plein la gueule est ce que comme géniale
idée vous aimez quand le corps de votre
partenaire et lui sur votre corps lourd
comme un cheval mort
est ce que comme dalida vous en avez
marre des paroles des paroles et non non
je vis de ça moi j'aime la communication
l'expression j'aime l'écriture j'aime
les mots j'aime le langage m le dialogue
et de la diplomatie
c'est sam je trouve c'est quelque chose
et c'est ce qui fait différent si
l'homme de l'animal quoi c'est
extraordinaire est ce que comme daniel
balavoine vous vous demandez ce qui
pourrait sauver l'amour mais pourquoi il
n'est pas en danger l'amour tant qu'il
ya des gens comme mélanie pour le porter
comme ça dans leur coeur pour leurs
mères et plus haut et puis si je pense
que mélanie si ingrid n'était pas ça
mais elle serait engagée dans ce combat
aussi pour une femme anonyme depuis
trois ans et demi que prisonnière dans
la jungle
j'en suis persuadé et si comme jane
manson
vous avez envie que nous fassions
l'amour nous avant de nous dire adieu
toi et moi ouais non
essaye pour voir et c'est un signe pour
misogynie pour attendre sexuelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en pointant au point des champs elysées
actuellement
pour santé c'est concret c'est beau et
bon d'accord il y aura des occasions
d'autres concerts sur un jeune arabe au
cours tout dans toute la france des
36000 communes de france le 23 février
prochain date du triste anniversaire de
la guerre et peut-être de la quatrième
année de détention d'ingrid betancourt
si elle n'est pas libérée d'ici là ça
sera une fête de la musique dans toute
la france des concerts partout pour la
liberté pour les otages en colombie en
asie
[Musique]